uh I don't know if a lot of people know
this but you and Jeezy ran into each
other at an airport damn Kev you know it
see do you talk you do interviews with
your friends they bring up [ __ ] did you
tell them nothing bad happened no they
bring up [ __ ] that you tell them in
confidence I didn't know this was in
confidence we edited it out no we don't
that happened it was a positive no we
don't edit [ __ ] when I come on here well
the last time you came home we did edit
a lot out well yeah because I want to go
to jail
um but now but you guys ran into each
other at the airport what happened oh
yeah I seen him at the airport
that's damn that's crazy bro this is the
first just we're all permitted [ __ ] but
uh
I see Jeezy at the airport uh with his
wife
I was with my girl and um
I seen him we shook hands and hugged and
[ __ ] was just like man salute it was
just like damn it was like a relief for
like both of us I feel like you know it
was like a hug or we exchanged numbers
and we both got on a plane that was it
that's a beautiful thing that it was it
was one of the most beautiful things
ever I think you could officially put
that behind you or it's like I've been
put it behind me but I had to like you
know like really I had to see him I had
to like really be in to be like really
officially be at peace with correct yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it would and then
when you look back man there wasn't
really nothing man I looked that was
[ __ ] a you know music disagreement
you know I mean like I didn't really
have none you know um against Jeezy I
looked up to Jeezy you know I mean she's
one of my favorite rappers you know I
mean I learned a lot from him I learned
to you know really how to carry myself
in this rap game by being around him so
um you know I think that that was just a
misunderstanding miscommunication
um it ain't like all of this other [ __ ]
with these other little [ __ ] [ __ ] when
I see them slap the [ __ ] out of them you
know what I'm saying but
with that even you know it'll be times
where we'll be in the same places
all the time it's the rap game of course
of course there wasn't nothing violent
happen or no [ __ ] like that or or nobody
was you know
disrespecting each other too bad you
know what I mean like you know we said
things but like for the most part man we
both men and I think that we was just
both trying to just get our points
across and we just just communicated it
badly and uh you know I take the blame
for that because I uh you know I should
have just like
sat tight and just let my work speak for
itself instead of like even like
speaking on it publicly at all you know
I mean I think that really what set me
off is when they asked him about me
publicly I wish he would have just
deflected that and but then I took that
[ __ ] too far and I you know I look at
that situation it's another learning
experience yeah I mean as long as you
get out learn from your fuck-ups man
yeah definitely I don't even say [ __ ]
ups just here yeah that was something
that I needed that was that was
something that I needed in my career you
know what I mean like I needed that
um that opposition so to speak you know
what I'm saying almost like how Jordan
would use like the littlest thing I feel
like you're very much like that because
I know the littlest [ __ ] that might not
be directed at you but sometimes you'll
be taking [ __ ] personal I'll tell you
yeah I'll tell you everything that
really confuses me
but you're very good at like taking the
smallest little like just whatever
somebody says or something that happens
and you use that as like motivation
that's why it's Tweety like oh the white
tweet like this my [ __ ] gonna be doing
and I'll be like I hate care of it man
you see this you see this [ __ ] right
here I'm just like I feed off of it man
like I'm competitive by Nature man so
it's like I feel like I gotta have
something to
not necessarily nobody or somebody in
particular to you know go against I
don't need that I just need some type of
motivation you know what I mean um and
maybe it it don't always got to be a
rapper that motivated me it could be
like a record executive that can tell me
that I ain't [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying or anything or a [ __ ] or [ __ ] my
baby mama telling me I can't rap all
kind of [ __ ] like they want to tell you
that huh when they mad at me but then
when the songs come out they were like
damn
you got the Grammy nomination yeah yeah
I love him too we all say [ __ ] that
about each other that we shouldn't say
but I love them though at the end of the
day